come on
[Music]
I have had enough of you then go before
I put you down
today you have proven worthy of joining
us
there are other Champions I must gather
and I won't give it up without a fight
enough
okay let's go back to one here
who are you again Lord Liu Kang
protector of Earth Realm god of fire
you have skills Raiden but you're
inexperienced whatever experience I lack
I make up for in heart
thank you
if your disease becomes known you will
be banished I only want what's best for
you or do you secretly covet my throne
foreign
[Music]
[__]
[Applause]
I mean that was pretty good right guys
now I'm sure you have many questions
about what we just saw and to tell you
more I am so honored to welcome to
summer game Fest one of our industry's
greatest creators a man who has been
loyal to the same franchise and fan base
for more than three decades please join
me in welcoming to summer game Fest the
creator of Mortal Kombat Ed Boone
[Applause]
congratulations
they love you all right well Ed uh first
of all thank you for that incredible uh
World premiere we got to see all the
gameplay of MK1 and everyone just wants
to know more about this because first of
all this is in a it's MK1 right we went
from 11 to one so tell us about this is
it a new timeline yeah yeah um I don't
know how many people have seen the the
ending of Mortal Kombat 11 Liu Kang
basically was kind of graduated into
like you know a fire god right and he's
he created a brand new universe and this
universe this is why we're calling it
Mortal Kombat one is because this is the
beginning of a new timeline a number of
these characters you've seen before but
they're told in a completely different
story and so Sub-Zero and Scorpion are
brothers now and there's there's all
these things that were rivalries before
are now allies and so mixing the whole
thing up so we're just kind of rebooting
and that's what the one is for well it
looks incredible everything we saw there
was you know in game gameplay the
cinematics look incredible I know the
team has been working for four years on
this but the thing we gotta talk about
are these cameos because we saw some
pretty amazing stuff there now tell us
how does that work you obviously you
have your sort of your main you know
character that you'll pick and then I
know you also have a separate kind of
Cameo menu so you pick sort of a pair
when you start the game yeah normally in
in a fighting game you'll you'll see a a
roster basically you know where you
select your character after you do that
there's a second roster of characters
which are a whole new uh completely
different Fighters that are the Cameo
Fighters and these Fighters actually
they will join the fight but the blank
squares there yes so it's kind of like
imagine yourself with sub-zero but you
have some of Jack's moves and you can
call him out you can do it multiple
times as you saw in the gameplay you
know so you can piece you can basically
combine these two characters all the
characters can be combined with all the
Cameo Fighters and that's where you see
that's where the players kind of
imagination comes in and they can
actually customize it for what they like
seeing you know the best team ups well
so how does that work so you're in game
gameplay you have your main you have
your cameo how do you do you summon them
is it time base like how often do they
come into it's not a tag team thing
right yeah yeah exactly and and you're
you're basically summoning them it's
just one button pushes basically
summoning but they have a variety so you
can go you know push that button with
towards and it'll do a different move
push it with down it'll do a different
move and so the combination oh I see so
you can bring them in a combo exactly
exactly and and so and you see there's
like a meter up on top which is
basically that that'll limit it so you
can't obviously fire them
indefinitely but um you call you can
call them pretty much whenever you want
and they have you know like in the
middle of a combo they'll have a lot of
um you know basically a whole arsenal of
their mood so Sony Utah come out there
sometimes you'll see them appear twice
in there to me so time base they come
out and then obviously as you go through
you revealed some of them there but is
it a different set of characters that'll
be in the cameos are there some repeats
from the main roster how will that work
yeah yeah some of the characters are
going to be available as cameos as well
as the main roster fighter so you can
play Sub-Zero with sub-zero right you
can play you can same thing with
scorpion but a lot of our our Cameo
Fighters are kind of like nods back to
our first game so you'll notice Sonia
and Kano and Jax are in their kind of
older costumes and so there's there's a
lot of that novelty we have a lot of
like really surprised ones I think you
guys saw Goro yes yes so there's a lot
of like kind of really digging into the
old Mortal Kombat games as far as
getting you know um we really love the
novelty of it we really want the Cameo
characters to feel uh you know kind of
Nod to the old games
well speaking of uh 90 old games let's
talk you confirmed I think or at least
knowing that Jean-Claude Van Damme is
actually going to be in this game as
Johnny Cage right is that true yeah
that was people don't know the story I
mean Bloodsport was such an inspiration
for Mortal Kombat so he finally is now
yeah it's a huge first uh full circle
moment you know the the first Mortal
Kombat game we originally wanted to be
Van Damme the video game and that and
that never really worked out so I I
can't tell you how many times over the
last 30 years we've tried to get him uh
you know we are this close like four or
five times and uh so finally we got him
and he's doing the voices too so you're
gonna hear John Claude his voice doing
Johnny Cage lines and stuff like that
we're really excited about it wow well I
know the team has been working so hard
in Chicago to build this through covid
and it's coming out in September so we
don't have to wait long right that's
right with this this has been a very
difficult uh secret to keep over the
last over the last four years and so uh
but we're
we could not be more excited in terms of
uh getting players hands on it
um and you know throughout the summer
we're going to be showing a lot more
content a lot more characters a lot more
Cameo characters you know so there's a
lot of reveals that are coming up
amazing well Ed thank you so much for
giving us the first look at MK1 as you
said this weekend people will be playing
at Preston media so we'll be seeing lots
more coverage lots more characters to
reveal on the main roster in cameos uh
Ed Boone thank you so much first look at
Mortal Kombat awesome
amazing